I will please God
I miss Sweden
I miss my words
take me back to where I belong
haha where am I
nicely polished minimalistic style and
kitchen could this could this be I mean
yeah Kia
yes oh the stuff it's amazing oh my god
oh this is so good this is so good Oh
what happens if I click on this flying
through the sky
on earth giris and dragon
take me to nan gay all right you got a
chair yeah you do that [ __ ] again I
swear to God come here
I hear you like a [ __ ] oh wow wow
that's a dragon Wow blessing it whoa
this is [ __ ] awesome all right I'm
going back in time guys holy [ __ ] that's
the big fish yeah you think I care the
POTUS is one creature you definitely
this is super lame what the [ __ ] is this
oh my god I'm on a bed ooh that's a nice
bed where am I
what is this place whoa that's creepy
this is actually really scary and weird
I don't like it what is this what is
this there's a demon here there's a
demon somewhere hello
this is to sexual again I'm sorry whoa
there's some flickering lights over
there hello oh my god someone's coming
up
why I know kung [ __ ] fool
I will did I break them Jesus Christ
throw the money I'll put it on the seat
there's a stupid teddy bear oh no come
on was that yeah I mean that was that
was it I can make a better game with my
[ __ ] mom in pain honestly I just
dance is that it there's something is
this some kind of furry trap
I'm not into your furry [ __ ] Thank
You dragon for giving me dancing power
catch your bull dragon
yeah
oh man I'm killing it I never stopped
and playing this game school marks my
youtube channel
thank you
that was pathetic be responsible with VR
you never know what's gonna happen and
don't you do drugs to alcohol but don't
do VR this has been cutie pie
I approve this message breakfast